we have a special emphasis on the unique
challenges that women face when they try
to negotiate when they try to manage
teams when they try to lead some people
find it very difficult to be
authoritative even when their role calls
for that some people find it very
difficult to ever defer to anyone
there's a lot of research that indicates
that women just don't choose to
negotiate in circumstances where men do
and this has tremendous implications I
[Music]
try to expand their expectations about
what is negotiation beyond an
adversarial win-lose kind of dynamic we
have them negotiate and I use their
results as the basis for the discussion
for developing a framework for how can
they be more effective what we deal with
in this course is understanding the
psychology that gets in the way of
feeling comfortable the opportunity to
step back and think in a more
big-picture kind of way about our goals
our aspirations the extent to which we
contribute to the bottom line in our
company one thing that came to my mind
during this last week was this whole
idea about powered the power in silence
the power in not acting is acting at
both Debbie and Maggie over in Syria
traded one knows these things it's just
a matter of seeing it from a different
perspective I would recommend this
program just to have a confirmation is
your leadership style okay do you need
to make any improvement we provide them
with specific strategies for dealing
with the problems that they face and
they're like I wish I'd had this years
ago this is transformed how I think
about this problem and you know it's
very cool when faculty members hear that
we have transformed your lives it's got
like oh yes this is what we're here for
[Music]